bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors la création
des policiers à herblay quelques jours
après l'attaqué du commissariat de
champigny sur marne
est ce que pour vous on assiste à une
hausse des actes antipolis où c'est un
phénomène qui a depuis quelques années
maintenant
alors il ya une hausse oui après cet
appel à mayenne malheureusement qui
arrive depuis des années on laisse faire
on ne fait rien on a eu des collègues
encore l'année dernière crs qui ont reçu
des lettres de menaces chez eux il ya eu
des quelques années avant des collègues
qui ont été interdits à tac est hors
service devant leurs familles donc dans
ce n'est pas nouveau par contre ce qui
est pas nouveau non plus et que les
pouvoirs publics ne font rien
malheureusement
et les sphères la nouveauté par contre
c'est que là on se prend carrément en
attaque un commissariat cirque c'est
puis des personnes isolées comprend dans
la rue parce qu on est plus nombreux
c'est qu'on a même plus peur d'attaquer
le centre où on où les policiers
travaillent alors comme on explique ce
phénomène est les policiers depuis des
années accumulent les heures
supplémentaires sont déployés à tort et
à travers sur tout et n'importe quoi on
est sûr mobilisés pour du maintien de
l'ordre notamment sur les mouvements des
gilet jaune et à côté de ça nous n'avons
plus de quoi assurer nos missions
quotidiennes des commissariats sont
déshabillés et on arrive à ce résultat
où il n'y a plus assez de policiers sur
le terrain pour ben justement faire de
la présence physique montrer que nous
sommes présents et nous occuper de la
délinquance de tous les jours plutôt que
de nous occuper
malheureusement de la coque du
gouvernement alors vous demander plus de
moyens concrètement quotidiennement dans
l'exercice de vos missions
de quel genre de mesures auraient besoin
les forces de l'ordre pour se sentir
plus efficace plus rassurés mais déjà
que c'est qu'on revienne à votre
principal métier qui n'est pas forces de
l'ordre mais gardiens de la paix s'est
on nous demande de courir après les
statistiques comme encore récemment
monsieur d'arbanats sur les statistiques
de
ii a dû stupéfiants on préférait plutôt
démanteler les trafics plutôt que
s'occuper des boulette de shit pour la
com du ministère on voudrait également
restaurer un lien entre la police et la
population parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya
une défiance vis-à-vis de la police
c'est ce qui permet d'arriver à ces
exactions
c'est que si ce lien n'est pas réparé on
n'arrivera à rien donc là on peut avoir
un ministre qui vient rouler des
mécaniques et bien dire des choses si on
ne revient pas à la fois une police de
prévention de répression derrière si ça
ne marche pas et avec une chaîne pénale
qui suit à la fin donc le système
judiciaire qui est aussi besoin de
moyens on arrivera juste à des positions
et du paraître et au final ce sera
toujours les mêmes dans la rue les
policiers qui seront attaqués et les
gens dans ces quartiers là qu'ils ne
pourront pas vivre en sécurité
alors vous parliez d'un lien cas c'est
comment justement on le fait pour le
réparer ce n'est pas seulement au
ministère j'imagine pas le ministère
déjà 6,12 à les consignes de je vais
donner un exemple très simple quand il
ya les plus anciens il ya 40 ans
rentrait au commissariat et marquer rien
à signaler tout est calme on leur disait
bravo le quartier calme félicitations
m'est encore des policiers reviennent de
patrouille et marc rien à 6h10 mais vous
êtes nuls vous n'avez pas mis de
contraventions nos statistiques c'est
très mauvais dans un autre commissariat
par exemple à fontainebleau l'année
dernière les fonctionnaires ont été
sanctionnés parce que les chiffres
étaient moins bons ils ont dit peut-être
qu'on a bien fait notre travail dont il
ya plus de la délinquance a baissé
donc on est sur une gestion statistique
est complètement déconnecté de la
réalité qui a vécu à la fois par les
policiers et par la population dans ces
quartiers donc en fait on arrive à cette
aberration il ya une incompréhension les
gens ne se sentent pas pris en
considération et notamment les victimes
les policiers ne peuvent pas faire leur
travail correctement parce qu'il ya
cette injonction de faire du chiffre et
delà de la politique du chiffre et des
statistiques
et ça n'a rien à voir avec la
tranquillité publique donc pour rétablir
ce lien il faudrait que les policiers
puissent retourner voir la population
puisse discuter avec eux plutôt qu'à
chaque fois qu'on soit éduquée et comme
des robocop pour aller parler à des
personnes et qu'on nous autorise à le
faire je vais prendre un exemple les
verts youtuber qui a fait le tour du
monde des police dont un au niveau
mondial donc et il a fini ses films et
avec elles et dans toutes les polices
dans le monde
les policiers rigole de son intervention
et plus film le seul endroit et se faire
interpeller c'est en france alors que
c'est quelqu'un qui aimait rigoler avec
eux donc il ya ce problème de ce lien
cas c'est qu'il faut absolument remettre
parce que les gens qui travaillent dans
ces quartiers qui vivent dans ces
quartiers dont qu'une envie c'est de
vivre tranquillement également alexandre
l'on va merci d'avoir répondu
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général du syndicat de police
vgik merci